[Música]
tú te acuerdas lo que hacías de los 18 a
los 23 años
yo me dedicaba a estudiar
bueno hacer como si estuviera para poder
vivir aquí en valencia lo
suficientemente lejos de mis padres para
que no me controlarán demasiado así
poder salir con mis amigos y amigas
todos los días y me de viaje festivales
erasmus no veía nada que me dejara por
hacer de hecho era la primera en hacerlo
todo en apuntarme a todo pero claro con
toda esta actividad los típicos las
entregas de los proyectos de la
universidad todos a última hora en el
último momento y la última semana que
nos faltará el café el redbull y las
horas y horas sin don bit ingeniando me
das para hacer en dos semanas lo que no
haya hecho en seis meses
suena algo de esto
la verdad es que a esa edad me lo pasaba
muy bien pero no tenía un propósito
claro en la vía me movía más bien por
inercia y no sabía muy bien para aquí
hacía las cosas mis motivaciones venían
de fuera hacia adentro es decir buscaba
el reconocimiento o la recompensa
inmediata para hacer las cosas
pero a un buen día la vida quiso
enseñarme algo tan valioso quien me
freno los pies de golpe y casi ni lo
cuento
una mañana
al despertarme en casa de mis padres
abrió los ojos y vi en el techo dos
lámparas iguales
pese a que está en un sueño en ese
momento y me volvía a dormir pero al
despertarme y abrir otra vez de nuevo
los ojos me di cuenta de que estaba
viendo doble
quería levantarme y mi cuerpo no
respondía a nada de lo que estaba
diciendo
de hecho toda mi parte derecha estaba
totalmente inmovilizado
del susto ya me he corriendo mi madre
como veis corre ayuda no sé qué me pasa
no puedo moverme
del cuello de mis padres conseguimos
llegar a el coche porque yo en este
momento apenas me andaba y volando nos
fuimos al hospital
en su momento recuerdo una escena
que fue cuando los neurocirujanos
entraron en la uci para contarme que me
estaba pasando yo ese momento no lo
sabía pero estaba sufriendo las secuelas
de un daño cerebral adquirido con tan
sólo 23 años
me dijeron que podía morir
podía morir tanto si me operaba como si
no me operaba y que en el mejor de los
casos saldría viva de aquella operación
pero con una lista interminable de
secuelas me impedirían llevar una vida
con normalidad
así sin poder ponerme de la cama bajo
ningún concepto estuve dos meses de mi
vida esperando aquella operación de vida
o muerte
fueron dos meses de mucha reflexión en
los que aprendí que el miedo la
tranquilidad o la paciencia y la
ansiedad solo estaban a un pensamiento
de distancia
y aunque me veáis aquí ahora de pie
hablando y comunicándome con todos
vosotros cuando salir de aquí la
operación no puede andar no podía comer
no podía ver y tenía muchas dificultades
para wii
al volver a casa evidentemente era una
persona totalmente dependiente
una de las pocas cosas que puede hacer
era leer
así que en ese momento apareció en mí
una increíble oportunidad y curiosidad
por saber que me estaba pasando y cómo
podía solucionarlo empecé a leer miles
de libros de páginas y blogs de
neurociencia rehabilitación psicología y
sobre todo historias de personas que
habían pasado por lo mismo y yo me di
cuenta de que éramos un montón y que en
españa cada año aparecen más de 100.000
nuevos casos por daño cerebral adquirido
esta cifra en el mundo asciende a más de
70 millones cada año
y es que el daño cerebral adquirido en
españa' es la primera causa de muerte en
mujeres y la segunda en hombres
pero no todo fueron malas noticias lo
que descubrí también descubrí que podía
recuperarme que podía volver a
levantarme ya retomar mi vida así que me
puse manos a la obra y junto con mi
familia amigos y profesionales me
ayudaron a recordar este difícil camino
pero os voy a contar un secreto
entonces el proceso de rehabilitación me
fijaba mucho en como los niños y las
niñas empiezan a caminar
empiezan a moverse
empiezan a hablar o caerse y al
levantarse así empecé
exactamente como ellos empecé a andar
gateando
empecé a escribir dibujando y empecé a
comer con un chupete en la boca sí con
un chupete en la boca a mis 23 años fue
como volver a empezar de cero en ese
momento
siempre durante ese proceso me venía a
la cabeza la misma pregunta
porque me ha pasado esto a mí
con el tiempo me di cuenta de cuál era
la pregunta correcta para quien me ha
subido esto a mí para que nos sitúa en
un espacio creativo de posibilidades
infinitas el por qué sólo satisface
nuestra mente el para que llena nuestro
corazón de propósitos y el sentido a lo
que hacemos
lo que se hace una rehabilitación de
otros años en tan sólo seis meses
conseguir recuperarme y retomar la
universidad para poder terminar mi
carrera en diseño gráfico y ahora así
con una con un propósito claro en la
vida el diseño al servicio es persona
quería devolver todo lo que había
aprendido de esta historia para ayudar a
mejorar la calidad de vida de personas
que habían pasado por lo mismo que yo
así que con la increíble ayuda y
asesoramiento del equipo profesional de
la asociación de innovación de valència
de año cerebral nos pusimos manos a la
obra y creamos un proyecto llamado the
cedar ya
un juego de mesa terapéutico para la
estimulación cognitiva de personas
adultas y de niños y niñas con
diferentes patologías como el autismo y
el alzheimer el parkinson el síndrome de
dawn el daño cerebral adquirido la
dislexia u otras muchas que derivan en
la dificultad de aprender del lenguaje o
la comunicación
desde al yo es un proyecto universal y
puede ayudar a mejorar la calidad de
vida el entorno y la autonomía de muchas
personas con diversidad funcional dentro
de sus casas colegios residencias
hospitales y clínicas de todo el mundo
no os voy a engañar emprender y recorrer
todo este camino está siendo una tarea
muy difícil pero a la vez emocionante
recientemente de cedar yo fue
seleccionado con uno de los 10 mejores
proyectos sociales liderados por mujeres
de toda españa tuvimos la oportunidad de
conocernos todas en un evento ya pesar
de que estábamos compitiendo por una
suma considerable de dinero para
nuestros proyectos nos conectamos de
forma natural teníamos muchas cosas en
común y sobre todo las ganas de pedí
cambiar el mundo con nuestros proyectos
que vienen de aquí adentro
vivir esta experiencia
me hizo ver que una nueva generación la
mía se abre paso insistente hacia esta
dirección y la razón es elemental se
busca uno para que un sentido a lo que
hacemos ya lo que aportamos a este mundo
vivir toda esta historia que se acaba de
contar me ha enseñado a parar
a pensar
ya no moverme por inercia hoy os
comparto mi historia para que no tengas
que pasar por lo mismo que yo
para el llegar a preguntaros cuál es la
causa de vuestra motivación con
experiencia por obtener una recompensa
inmediata o realmente la causa de gusto
motivación bueno viene de vuestro
interior
de la necesidad de hacer las cosas al
servicio de algo más grande que nosotros
mismos
[Aplausos]